so Rick you were interviewed years ago
for the first part of the trilogy and
you said that you know a filmmaker
should almost let go of wanting to be in
control or even caring about what
happens to a film after it's released
how do you know it's true yeah how do
you how do you let that go I mean
because so much of it is really life or
death to the artists will people approve
it will be known for distribution well I
think filmmakers are pretty control
freaky type people and you can only
control it so far you know pretty soon
as it is out there in the world and you
don't have any control over what people
think of it or what its ultimate life is
so it's probably a healthy relationship
to have you know right do not be so
attached yeah yeah but you're attached
no matter what cuz you put a lot of
yourself into it you know you put the
time and effort it means something to
you but it's funny the afterlife things
have I mean we're still messing with the
afterlife of that particular movie by
doing two more you know so we that one
never leaves us